On July 26, 1971, the Apollo 15 space module
touched down on the moon and astronauts
emerged with a new vehicle, the Lunar Rover.
They took it for a test drive.
It handled well on the rough surface of the
moon so they could venture further from the
landing site and really explore.
The lunar rover was no ordinary four
wheeler.
Millions of dollars of research went into
this one horsepower wonder, which became
known as the moon buggy.
Today, craftsmen build replicas for space
museums and to use as movie props.
The team starts with the substantial
suspension system designed to smooth the ride
over the moon's rocky terrain.
Then they install a steering plate at the
front.
They attach actuators, which are mechanisms
that assist in steering.
They connect the actuator drive bars to the
steering plate.
Together, the steering plate and actuators
give the lunar rover an incredibly tight
turning radius of just over three meters.
They screw support brackets for the
actuators to the corners of the chassis.
Then they connect the actuators to them.
They use steel and aluminum bolts and parts.
However, on the original moon buggy, many
parts were made of titanium because it
lightened the load carried into space.
Titanium is expensive and unnecessary for
this replica.
The fenders are next.
They are extra large to protect astronauts
from.
Lunar dust kicked up by the rover.
They insert a locking mechanism in a slit at
the end of the drive shaft and slide the
wheel hub onto the shaft.
They turned the hub to lock it in place, and
they're now ready for the wheels in the
atmospheric vacuum of the moon.
Airfield rubber tires were out of the
question, so the original rover had wire mesh
tires to mimic the look.
They've wrapped a wire lattice around rubber
tires.
The team secures the wheel to the hub with a
plastic and aluminum cap that's equipped with
locking pins.
They give it a spin and install the other
three wheels.
Next, a technician assembles the instrument
panel.
He inserts various switches and gauges into
their slots.
Including this system reset switch.
It's used to bring the displays back to zero
prior to an expedition.
He closes a two piece collar around the
bottom of the switch.
He locks it in place with a top cap.
He then flips the panel around and tightens
the nut on the back part of the switch.
With the system reset switch now snug to the
board.
The instrument panel is complete.
He places it in the housing.
He installs metal bars around the switches
to keep them from being accidentally tripped.
He assembles the steering handle, which is a
t shaped joystick next to the instrument
panel. They now transfer the steering and
Instrument panel assembly to the vehicle.
They fastened the actuator switches to the
steering housing.
And then clip the wiring harness to the
floor of the lunar rover.
They cover the bottom of the rover with flame
resistant material.
They lower the electrical control panel and
battery into the chassis and connect them.
The original rover had two small batteries,
but the mechanics of this replica have had an
update. The production of this lunar rover
replica continues with the fabrication of a
brake disc.
The technician carefully measures the
dimensions and draws them onto a sheet of
plastic covered aluminum.
He drills a large hole for the main drive
shaft and four screw holes.
He then cuts out the disk following the
penciled lines.
He smooths the rough edges using a fine grit
abrasive belt.
His hands off the plastic liner and a braids
the aluminum surface to a satiny sheen.
The brake disc is now ready for assembly to
the lunar rover.
He attaches it to the main drive shaft and
lowers the assembly into the vehicle.
He bolts the disk to the chassis where it
will serve as a friction surface for the
brake pads which he installs next.
He connects it to a spring mechanism for
engaging the disc brake.
He tests the drive shaft and disc brake and
confirms that they're both in working order.
He loops a roller chain around the sprocket
gear for the rear wheel drive and the teeth
into mesh. He drives pins through the links
to join the ends, closing the Loop.
This drive chain is powered by an electric
motor.
It's another mechanical modification on the
original rover.
There was a small motor for every wheel and
no drive chain.
The lawn chair, like seats are next.
They cover the shocks and battery at the
front with an aluminum hood.
They also install a cover over the mechanics
at the back.
It doubles as a rack for tools for
geological excavation.
They attach the umbrella antenna to the
rover.
It was used to beam pictures and data to
earth.
Next, an aluminum cylinder spins in a lathe
as cutting tools transform it into a mount
for a film camera.
They also machine a bracket for a
communications antenna.
It's quite a transformation.
Using the bracket, a member of the crew now
erects the communications antenna.
He then installs the mount for the film
camera.
Next. Using a sheer press, he lops off a
piece of an aluminum sheet.
He switches to a hand tool and cuts out a
geometric shape with flaps.
He folds up the flaps using a brake press,
creating a box to cover the main battery.
After the seams have been welded.
He wraps the cover in Mylar, which is a
strong plastic film.
The wrap is an extra layer of protection
against wind borne particles known as micro
meteoroids. They also wrap the camera and
other parts of the rover with Mylar.
This replica of the Apollo lunar rover is
complete and ready to expand the universe of
the curious.